hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
standing with my good friend troy what's
up brother what's up now listen you may
have heard of a strategy called rent to
rent rent to rent what's rent to rent
rent to rent is literally where you rent
a property
give the landlord a fixed price and then
rent out the rooms individually or rent
out as a service accommodation to get a
higher rent so then make profit right so
you you did this strategy you've been
we're working together the last couple
years and you did this in bristol you
rented houses turned them to hmos
how's that been going for you it's it's
been amazing to be honest it's been
amazing we've got a portfolio of like 38
different rooms we've got seven
different properties now and uh yeah
literally all the tenants are amazing
the cash flow is fantastic as well and
in terms of the cash flow actually uh
we've got i believe it's
5k cash flow now from the property so
yeah it's so you got to the point you
may have seen troy on winners on a
wednesday he became financially free
left his job absolutely fantastic but
now this guy is going to new levels what
what's just happened
so what has happened literally so from
the the last time we had the show right
the winners on a wednesday uh so
we got a couple more hmos and then we
also focus on actually getting
multi-unit apartments so we've got a
small block in west brom six apartments
in west brom and then we've got this
beautiful building right here look at
this
okay how have you got the balls man to
pitch the developer on this massive
block well you see
it's it's mainly the area right when you
know the area is going to work for short
term accommodation it's like just just
go for it you know and also if there's
hotels in the area like how do they
normally do things your thinking has
just got bigger and bigger and bigger so
now now you're thinking like a hotel
owner yeah and a lot of hotels by the
way folks don't be under the illusion
that hotel owners own the hotel building
oh yeah most hotel owners they lease the
building and then they turn into a hotel
that's exactly what my man troy's done
with this block he's leased the whole
building pretty much well a couple
floors yeah and and now you're you're
turning it into a hotel let's go look
around see how you're doing this bro
let's go
a lot of service accommodations like
normally they don't always have parking
yeah right this place you've got parking
for everyone so there's all these
parking spaces there also parking spaces
around the back as well yeah and also a
private gated entry as well so literally
it's nice and secluded nice and secure
when the guests come in
they're going to be safe as you can see
here we've got two vans
landlord furniture packages they're
helping us furnish the whole lot so yeah
helping us shout out to landlord
furniture packages uk yes give them a
follow give them a shout out all right
so what what why are you not packing why
are you not doing this yourself i know
when you started i remember you going to
ikea you'd be flat packing yeah yeah
what was it that made you decide to get
somebody else to come and do the work
literally it's just it's too much time
you know and it doesn't make sense
either because for example we're setting
up i think two different hmos 10
bedrooms right and um it took like over
a week just to get like all of the
furniture in right when you can actually
get a company and they'll start out in
like a couple of days right and when you
do something with this size yeah this is
big so you can't be you can't be getting
down on your hands and these flat back
and everything no way so okay cool
there's there's a summit what's this as
well
[Laughter]
number one key to success don't be a
little [ __ ]
so okay so your guest gets here how
they're getting in what's
how they're getting in so
they'll get a key first of all and where
they're gonna get the key from so the
key they're gonna get the key from a key
safe so we're gonna should be probably
on the wall or something yeah so we're
probably gonna have it somewhere here
and there's literally it's gonna be you
know 14 different 14 different boxes
yeah and then essentially so the book on
they'll get an email they get told this
is how you get in this is your number
they'll come they'll tap in the code tap
your tape
and then and then what do they get then
they get a key they get the wonky and
also a fob the blue fog all right so
then they get the fob
they're gonna hit hit this here
which is gonna give them access to get
in yeah and then they're gonna come in
okay so you're gonna so instead of
having like a receptionist here
which most people would do most hotels
have a receptionist and they say hello
and they'll check them in you're not
going to do that you're going to
streamline it which is going to save you
30 000 pounds a year on paying a
receptionist then you've got to pay them
their pension you don't have to give a
key save a pension
all right no no no employment rights
streamlined and actually better for the
guest yeah yeah because it's you know
because even with this there's kobe
stuff as well you know it's totally
contactless so they come in do their own
thing checking at their own time as well
no one wants no one wants to sit and
fill a form out and chat they just want
to do it streamline no one wants to wait
in the queue for the receptionist to be
like can i get your name can i check you
in just let me get in you know what i'm
saying so that makes sense okay so is
this your floor yes this is one of the
floors that we've got so currently we've
got the furniture still going in so it's
going to be a little bit here and there
but uh we're going one apartment real
quick all right so you've literally got
how many so you got one two
three four five six seven seven seven
apartment blocks yes seven take us in
one brother all right let's go to this
one number one
so yeah as i said it's still getting set
up but
you can look in the bathroom have a nice
look in there so
nice in you yeah nice
cool
all right and then
coming to here we've got the kitchen
dining area so still getting the
furniture coming out you know got the
mirrors pictures sofa and all these
appliances but you should you can a
hotel room can't compete with the
machine as well washing machine kitchen
this is like the equivalent of booking a
hotel suite yeah you've got a
lounge area kitchen area private
bathroom
and then you've got so is this a twin
room this is a twin room yes
so
some of some of the apartments uh you
know they've got bigger rooms than
others but yeah this is the one of the
ones with the the biggest rooms will
this always be a twin or would you
sometimes make it a double or what uh so
it depends on what the guest wants we
can make it a double because you can put
it together but you know not all of the
rooms have double beds as well so we
sort of want to accommodate for
everybody right a bit of individuality
in the rooms yeah okay so ground floor
and then you've got the next floor above
as well so in total how many how many
apartments have you got so in total it's
14 14 14 yeah and how much are you
paying the developer how much you're
paying the rent
985 times 14 so around about 13k
14k about 14 000. so you have to hold on
a minute you have to commit
to paying the developer
14 grand a month yes if you don't manage
to get guests in
you're screwed
yeah it's the potential
but but the thing is this you started
doing this with one house one apartment
you've
you've built your way up you've done
your market research you've been on air
dna you've done all your research around
this area to know actually i mean with
any with any business there's risk of
course most people would risk 800 quid a
month on their first property you're
risking 14 grand a month yeah how long
have you got the contract over so it's
over three years over three years and um
yeah essentially just just a point on
that in terms of going for the 14k so as
you said you know we started with one
property and then we kept on building it
up so
when you see that something works right
and you got you got the proof of concept
yeah it just makes sense to
keep on going in on you know scale it up
and then
that's that's how you have to go right
right it's great so
yeah literally tell me upset i want to
look at the the block upstairs but it's
nice
so that whole floor
ready to be filled with your guests yeah
and then this next floor is crazy you've
got a lift in here yeah this man's got a
lit
oh it's got a lift i love it all right
so yeah we're on the the first floor now
uh this is really really nice isn't it
yeah it's just brand new i love it this
is why we have to go for the brand new
apartment it feels very corporate yes
you only got seven up here as well
so this whole floor is yours yeah that's
right that's right i'll take into full
in let's go tape mate
so oh this is beautiful show you the
room first this is all ready now
yes yes look at this
and also the area as well it feels
industrial industrial
but it is just off of the big main road
in slough we're right next to all the
shops retail everything's here also not
sure if you know yeah slow it's got the
number one trading estate in in europe
so like in terms of biggest biggest one
so a lot of companies like ferrari dhl
they all work there as well so this is
why it's really good for the corporate
clients yeah yeah it is you know that
you're from bristol right yes gloucester
gloucester yes so managing wise
are you gonna are you gonna be here much
are you gonna just streamline it oh so
um in terms of that
we're gonna have uh like three cleaners
so one's gonna be a cleaning supervisor
then we'll have two cleaners and then
the cleaning supervisor they'll act as a
property manager right until we have
more units in the area to get a property
manager right and then yeah other things
are just systemized as well so you know
you've got the the key save so we don't
have to come down give people the keys
we've got minute alarms as well that
will detect uh like people having pies
for example then we've got systems in
place so you got what in place for that
a minute alarm so like tell me about
that it detects um it detects noise it's
like a noise detector alarm right and
it's literally once we get it's going to
go on like on there on the ceiling and
then
when there's like a loud noise for over
10 minutes we get notified in an app
right then if they keep on doing that we
then call out security security come
to take them out who would who's
security though who are these
who's security so it's a security
company
that we use right name of them
i don't remember what she is
but you use the security but you're
using the security and presumably you're
only paying per call out yeah and it
gets deducted from the people's deposit
as well right they appeared that's the
genius thing troy
if you have a hotel the traditional way
you've got to pay a member of staff to
be at reception you've got to pay a
security person in case there's a
problem but you've got a little a little
alarm
that says
if you're being too noisy we're not
going to have a full-time security guard
at the at the reception but we're gonna
a freelance company that will come out
and we'll only pay when and you're not
gonna pay
it's gonna come out of their deposit
exactly so clever
but you're only able to do this because
you started small yes that's so clever
well honestly mate the finish is is
fabulous and i know that it's not quite
finished yet i know you're gonna have to
get the uh the tv on a stand and there's
a few bits and bobs but yeah really nice
talk to me about talk to me about
finance in terms of
you're paying 958 pounds per month per
apartment yes 985 985 sorry i got my
money mixed how much profit are you
expected to make per apartment so if if
if if if i'm paying 958 to the landlord
i'm also having to pay bills yeah more
time to pay cleaning costs what kind of
turnaround are you obviously you don't
know exactly because it's a business
what are you improving what are you
forecasting per month
in terms of it being at 75 percent it
will be 750 pound profit if it's at 85
percent it'll be 1 000 if it's 100
1 600. it's never going to be 100 now
yeah
it may be but it's not that if it's if
we got like long contractor booking well
that's true yes but it's true we'll be
at the top so what what percentage in
this area are you expecting so if you
look on air dna literally the lowest
percent that the the top so 85
percentile people get yeah is eighty
percent eighty percent so you're
expecting a minimum of eighty percent
yeah and if it's eighty percent what
we've been making per month for eighty
percent will give us uh
one thousand pound
about a grand yeah so if you're getting
a thousand pounds per apartment
yes your overheads every month are a lot
you're having to pay the landlord almost
14 grand but your profit at the ground
that's 14 grand a month
on
one deal yeah yeah that's interesting
which is which is very realistic if it's
less if it's 10 grand a month it's still
good yeah yeah it is but we want to
obviously maximize it as much as
possible
you didn't look happy with 14 grand you
wanted more yeah yeah
i want to be getting the 1-6 but you
know
the first uh few months we're gonna have
to sort of focus on optimizing the
listings making sure that we're not the
best but get the reviews up as well
exactly exactly so yeah we'll get there
that's the thing so per night
how much talking about those figures
that we just talked about how much money
if i wanted to stay here for a night
roughly what are you talking
so
we want to aim for 129 pounds so
initially we're gonna start 77 just to
get the the bookings going in terms of
airbnb get the reviews in but we're
gonna push up to one two nine because as
you can see it's top quality apartments
people are getting reasonable try and
show me a place that's as good as this
right and at like
a higher price
i think i think that sounds fair so i
think that sounds fair and and you've
got still got cushion
to come down if you have to but with
with serviced accommodation like this
it it it depends on the day anyway
doesn't it it depends on how if how if
it's the weekend the holidays and
seasons that's where you guys really
clean up
over those sort of summer holidays
christmas period that's where you're
going to get a load of money coming in
and then some other months you might
just make a bit of money and you have to
look at it as an average over the year
anyway let's go into 11. so show you the
beautiful lounge that we've got right
here beautiful airy space you sound like
an estate agent now listen this is
it's from it's from the reds
around
show me around now brother you know
you know what though
they're all a little different but
they're kind of the same same sort of
thing let me ask you a question troy
what what
some people might say to you you can win
windows on a wednesday maybe six months
a year ago
you came on you're financially free
making 5 000 pounds a month
what drives you
to want to continue growing and scaling
why don't you just now you've already
quit work what did you used to do
an accountant did you enjoy it yeah yeah
so
essentially i always had dreams to like
get to a certain point be my own boss
and also drive nice cars go on holiday
when i want and i was like how am i
really gonna do that in the place i'm in
now right right so when i saw your video
about you know getting into property you
know many downside
property is a great choice right and
this is the way to actually get there so
yeah that's did you have a lot of money
when you started
no no no no
how much do you start with so
i think we started with like around
about a grand or two so just just enough
to sell the company right how did you
afford to join the academy so with the
academy we actually got a loan from our
family
oh wow
who who actually parents yes yes yeah
but how old i am i how old am i yeah i'm
24. 24. yeah man i've got to say a big
respect because a lot you know what it's
like you've got a low noun stuff you
really put your neck on the line this is
for you this like hat to work hello
hello
you've done so well as well
thank you very much so talk me through a
little bit about um how you've one of
the things i admire so much about what
you've done troy is the way you've
pulled your family into this now yeah so
talk to me about
serena
uh everybody and what's kind of what
your big vision is with this because
this is more about you making loads of
money in the comments you just want your
own right no it's it's not about that no
we want to get everybody in you know
friends and family and as you can see
serena she's now in the business as well
so you know she's got a share in the
apartments also the products as well
yeah have you got one a particular
property or just
uh sharing the whole thing so i've got
my own property in cheltenham oh no i'm
in here
i mean yeah what's the setup like
absolutely like so out of the 14 we do a
profit share right so
because there's three directors in
luxury stays we've got four essentially
serena's got one
right yeah yeah so out of the 14
apartments
you've got one
and as a and as a result you're helping
out with the whole thing yes yeah okay
i'm in charge of interior design and i'm
in charge of the
like whole set of this sort of stuff
like so you're bringing your family in
now yes that's right
i'll give you one of the apartments and
you can keep all the cash flow yeah so
it's
she's the director of the company right
right so the whole profit that comes
into the company is split right
how do you feel about that i feel like
really just grateful because obviously
seeing troy key like you know progress
and seeing that when i was on wednesday
view i was like wow they've just come
such a long way in such a short space of
time and like when troy said he was
ready to expand and start in service
accommodation i felt very like oh wow
okay so what are you thinking to do and
then when he said about you know making
it a more of a luxurious approach i was
like right i'm ready for it and i'm
ready for the
a full challenge yeah because because
you've been bringing like loads of your
family in yeah your friends
are your parents in uh
not yet now
they'll come in soon
why is it important to you to bring
people in on the on this business like
just because from being financially free
and getting the money from property i'm
like
it's actually so amazing and i just want
to share it with the friends because
essentially they've been so much like
big support to me as well throughout the
whole journey and i'm like you know what
i want to make you happy i want to get
this for you as well yeah i have a job
right yeah
he goes to jamaica
yes
that's the rippling effect i always talk
about though because like how i've
installed um training and stuff into you
confident support training and you
became financially free and then you're
helping serena yeah he's someone that
suggested me to come to your crash
course as well so then
what did you think of the crash course i
thought it was that's what made me start
at nsa that's what made me start my
business and like you know have the
confidence yeah actually put myself out
there and just do what i could and yeah
i didn't start off with one and then i
got another one then i left the other
one but then i got another two and then
yes it's just all been over the place
but wow it's been amazing yeah making i
think maybe a grand profit over the
house i've got in child now well
now this and being a director of the
whole thing yeah another thing is what
you know it's really good choice rather
than giving handouts to your family what
you're doing is you're bringing them in
on the business yeah which is just so
good yeah so yeah they're they're
investing right because they get a part
of the profit share you know yes yes
it's exciting i'm just excited i'm so
excited like i'm so proud of you guys
welcome
thank you very much so please
well done bro how do you feel knowing
that this is all
controlled by you i mean it must be a
good feeling
yeah it's it's really good it's really
good you know it gets me excited because
the thing is that we're bringing
friends and family along the way as well
and it's just like the work that we put
in yeah the flowers are starting to
blossom
and literally getting all the thank you
cards from everybody yeah the more
successful you are the more people you
can help you know
the more you know so
massive respect man honestly did you
think you'd come this far when you
started a couple years ago yeah did you
think you'd be this successful i think
i'm gonna be here no i wanted to get 20
rentals i was the first he said that was
the goal for the end of the year yeah
yeah
i didn't picture it being like this to
be honest
shout out time i know we've obviously
worked really closely together and we've
you know got you started everything like
that there's been a lot of people along
the way they've supported you guys
helped you out so um let's do a few
shout outs and he went to shout out a
few people yeah definitely so i want to
give a big shout out to sister also
family also katie is back and have been
very great support um also big shout out
as well massive thanks to james murphy
okay for actually introducing us to this
model actually uh contacting developers
and getting big more units like this so
big shout out to james also furniture
company very very thank you big thank
you for actually helping us set all of
this up landlord furniture packages and
big shout outs yourself as well samuel
the academy everybody on there as well
literally
it wouldn't have started without going
on the academy you know and yeah i
really appreciate was what you've given
to me
so well and also you know what guys also
the investors as well like you started
with nothing yeah and yeah not only your
family that invested in you but you've
had a lot of a lot of your deals the way
you've structured though even the way
you treated this one although you're
helping your family you've been bringing
investors onto your deals that's true as
well so big big thank you as well to the
investors because as really said you
know started literally nothing and you
know thankful taking and putting the
trust into me to actually you know make
all of this successful and then
get yourself you know what you why
investors want to invest in you because
you've made yourself invest a lot of
people like i need someone to give me a
break it's like give yourself a credit
right give yourself a break i want
people to invest in me invest in
yourself
you invested in yourself yeah now people
want to invest in you and that's why
people are surrounding themselves to
help you because success breeds more
success yeah so um biggest advice to
someone getting started what would you
say
biggest advice
i'd say definitely get to the questions
you need to get to the crash course to
know how to actually do this stuff but
as well as well
as well
big point as well is that
you need to really focus on one thing
until you get successful
because literally there's going to be so
many setbacks right you're going to want
to do other things but if you literally
just focus on the one thing until you
get successful um that will allow you to
actually get a success and then help you
do other things as well so amazing focus
on one thing until successful that's so
true well guys massive respect hey i
hope you enjoyed that since when do you
get to see massive tours like this i'll
tell you where on the samuel league's
youtube channel we're success student
after success studio if you want to join
the pie why don't you go ahead and
subscribe to the channel you want to
really join the party comment down to
the property investors crash course it's
free i'll leave a link in the
description hope you enjoyed this guys
peace out god bless you next time